[Music]
this week we've got musical message yes
impossible sandals Oh and Marvel parody
I hope the paw impossible sandals is
well yeah a dog with four sandals on his
boots I mean have you tried putting
shoes on your dog oh no no baby look
[ __ ] hilarious when they walk around
with them it's so funny yeah it's a frog
first story there's this girl named
Crystal 22 years old that she recently
moved back to Phoenix and she was saying
that being in that city is really hard
for her because her older sister where
did she move to and then where does she
like he was in Texas and then she moved
to Phoenix back to Phoenix so she's
originally from Phoenix anyway the point
is that she doesn't matter let her just
sit doesn't matter
alright you went to California you're
gonna [ __ ] back in this [ __ ]
right but if you move too if you move to
Kansas you're like damn oh thank God I'm
back in but that doesn't even matter in
this fan just letters leaking worthless
alright doesn't even matter yet so she's
saying that's really hard moving back
because her older sister she had passed
away and she had like chronic kidney
related issues
oma eight years older than her so eight
years ago her sister path yeah she's the
same age I her sister was when she
passed so anyway she was passing by the
hospital where she was I saw this okay
go ahead go you're not supposed to learn
I already seen this before I know the
story already my sister showed me
yesterday how ironic how'd you feel
about it I'm just kidding coach
afterwards this for this for what I want
to know the story as good those Darby
invited her sister's old hospital she
heard this song that goes like this
this is way too good
I know this song so she heard the chorus
because it says I what is it like I just
came I say hello to say hello but she
heard the radio say this
how did she record that like right let
me be kept going crystal says hello
Kristi no so this is Christmas or her
sister's name was Kristi so then she had
heard the chorus this is the third time
they played it and so the first tooth
like the first time she was just like
what and then the second time she was
like no wait until the third time she
pulled out her phone you should pull out
her phone while she was driving like a
reckless piece of [ __ ] it's like
interstellar when he's trapped in the
bookcase yeah he's like Kristi's trapped
inside the radio what is the actual
lyric I just came to say hello say hello
so then when she got home she showed her
family and like they just started
googling everywhere for like all
renditions of this type of song and to
see if there was any like does it sound
the same it didn't sound the same okay
so it is that song okay and so she
tweeted that out and she tweeted it with
the caption my sister Kristi passed away
eight years ago and I recently moved
home to our home state Arizona and right
before this I was crying because I
passed by her hospital the song
originally says I just came to say hello
here it says hey Kristi says hello
that's Jim I heard that ritual again
because I want to hear the voices sound
is definitely the same otherwise someone
could have just recorded it and then put
it on the video and just telling the
whole world on Twitter and I don't
believe it maybe my heart wants to
believe my heart believe
The Voice is pretty similar and then
this is uh you've got chills this is
Chris crystal always be never having
normal picture anymore those filters I
don't know who the [ __ ] you are those
paw prints what are those they're fire
fire but it doesn't matter like contour
your face it blows it out bigger yeah
that's all that make you like an anime
character she's the one that was driving
recklessly no she's the one that passed
oh when they were together I mean we're
all in there the babies yes this is
she's the reckless driver the baby yeah
this is Kristy this is Crystal Palace i
taiked right there I don't see it I
don't see it yeah DJ I was playing at DJ
with the name DJ know the actual DJ from
the radio I was like what are you
talking about just about the disc jockey
of the radio station no but I was hoping
his name or her name would be DJ Chris
Villa in freaking text me yeah yeah
crispy yeah and so the DJ said this I
know it doesn't exactly say your
sister's name it says mine Chris via but
I'm sure I was meant to play it for you
that day from your sister oh oh so it's
supposed to say Chris B says hello Chris
B or via also it's one of those like
remixes for the radio station
you're late again but that is a trip
though that is amazing I told you it
wasn't real
why don't you just believe her you win i
freakin cold-hearted I like - are you
sure I've seen you with her bright
hopeful has its head off the window in
this [ __ ] winter passenger and parked
sure now is it a park movie yeah oh he
was back see balls and passenger at all
sure yeah sure dog I can't be film me
like this I don't like signs from
[ __ ] God and stuff man Oh he'd be
talking to me on my bro I mean northern
you did I'm trying to be hope I tried I
don't need this right now man I always
want to talk to spirits but they don't
want to [ __ ] talk so I don't believe
in this stuff I really really don't and
I try to just like stick to says the
girl who's afraid it goes I know she
doesn't want to believe because it
scares her yeah yeah I don't want it cuz
I don't know if it exists or doesn't and
I just don't want to find out if it's
real okay cut me a [ __ ] break but I
do believe you believe in it alright are
you scratching at my door um yeah I
don't believe in this stuff but then
when my dad passed he's known for
collecting a bunch of quarters right and
then me my mom all my family they
started just randomly finding like
quarters in places like let's say I pick
up this water ball and it was like a
quarter there and we were like what the
[ __ ] so I'm still kind of like you know
there's your money your money that's all
there might be a quarter fairy I don't
really use cash hmm so for me to find
quarters and really random places I was
just like all right well someone dropped
it like I try to justify it but it's
weird a cabinet where you have all your
canned food there's like a quarter there
I hope one day when Barton you're boning
and he's hitting it from behind you're
bent over you like reach under the
pillow and you find out you like the
fortified
funny disgusting
you you need a hugger if she reached and
there was just a pile of quarters oh my
god look at the [ __ ] quarters and his
George Washington frowning dad's face in
the corner like yeah that shouldn't be
crazy I'm gonna go find a picture your
dad I'm gonna have it minted on quarters
and I'm hiding I can't wait till you get
rich - Oh Jo you Steve need to be
billionaires I haven't seen a quarter in
years what I don't know a quarters look
like I think they're at the orange ones
yes I think so too
okay next story there is this really
weird product that is being sold in a
Japanese shop that's about everything
that died so yeah everything is weird
together these sandals sandals oh it's
awesome money to buy these bo are you
willing to spend four hundred and ten
dollars honestly y'all [ __ ] crazy I
am did they make the neck do we sound
like actual like hugs hoofprints we've
seen those enough outstanding McQueen
shoes oh wait no toaster claws but
there's shoes like these so you got to
get it with your best friend and then
you hold each other like this and you
spoon your best friend and you walk
together I wish I could see this in
action you know I want to hear them -
they're not - oh oh that's a dope
picture that is a pickle fish dude they
have shoes like this already this is
like 2013 like it was when all the girls
had a Wheaties oh then you could be a
centaur what your homie then one of the
one of your friends are in the back like
that yeah and so they also come in red I
like the pink ones
can someone get those for me please and
they make a guy wears it for real why is
it so expensive it looks like dope cuz I
think that [ __ ] old Japanese man made
him
garage questions it matter would ya what
lovely real horse hooves what
yikes that would have been cool wait
what did you say no wonderful that's
what I wanted wheels us without hurting
the horses of course yeah they get
passed away then you took 400 bucks
right there
why is that bad I mean when you go to
the pet store they have that for the
animals to chew no yeah the horse hooves
don't B's it's humanely I don't they use
that for jello really yeah yeah jello
it's not a hook well what did they do
now like it was before ground the hooves
I thought it was cow fat those things or
bones no it's horse I think it's horse
hoof see let's let's verify that well I
think it's bow I think I think it's cow
fat I don't really think it [ __ ]
matters why cuz you don't like jello
because horse hooves are savage as you
guys think it is that comes from boiling
bones
oh it's Bob but hooves consist of a
different protein keratin which can't
produce gelatin no so know who other
house is the one of those like you know
when your your your fatty foods get cold
it was like a jello on top that's it
nasty have you ever had like a soup and
then you put it in the Frigidaire that's
all Mexican food dude it's like a jelly
gel all Mexican food is like that well
that's delicious that's why Mexican food
is so good everything is made with lard
Obama lard oh yeah lardo lardo dude did
you ever see what that looks like this
is big it's like an oversized stick of
butter it's all white it's it's
different so like you'll see a lot of
that like for example in Jewish food
like a filter fish that's actually like
in a lot of fish is within the bones
called pectin and that's how you get
that gelatinous stuff the [ __ ] that
you're talking about is actual fat its
lard it's large pig fat so people who
actually cook know that woman so shut
the hell up anyways continue when you go
to the Mexican market it's a white box
like this my mom used to cook with that
yeah it's not just the mothers with that
that's why Jewish people they also call
schmaltz like the chicken fat and they
use that in a lot of the cooking small
and that's chicken fat and that's what
isn't
yep well that makes things too so they
raise a lot of animal fats yeah mm-hmm
yeah don't put it on shoes put it in my
food man I know I would love I would
love to wear these pair I still want to
tell the tale
more than functioning one you ever
members we had like it yeah like however
you're feeling that's tight you're
emotional when your ears wagging hope
you add more Vitosha I to tell to like a
fox Taylor I would have styled that [ __ ]
differently you imagine you got a rat
tail and I wouldn't expose the human
feet it would be a boot a furry boots so
it looks like an actual horse's foot
yeah yeah and the fur would go all the
way up to your vagina so your whole leg
just looks like the girlfriend Oh kind
of cool like some [ __ ] me boots like it
turns into like shoe chaps shoes uh we
should be designers oh I've seen
something that before they're like pants
all invested Oh like the gr like the
Chuck's one yeah the whole thing goes
all the way up is a pair of pants mm-hmm
dummy should ever see my life you've
never seen those pants boobs boobs you
don't like those vinyl pants with the
with the shoes already inside yeah damn
how do you even wash those it's it's
just the adult onesies dryclean only
shiny ones nice basic garden yes damn
all right last story those guys in
Malaysia that did this they recreated
the adventures infinity war trailer
their own style that's a dope seeds a
get a one yeah I need to get caught up
on this I'm still stuck on civil we're
all coming at all coming out like having
watch the borea it's like seven Marvel
movies a year some [ __ ] oh I need to do
what parts of it we officiate yes this
whole parody thing even got the
attention of the Russo brothers they
tweet who the [ __ ] are by other ones are
directed the directors if I have to move
so I'll show you a 30-person I'll show
you what they tweeted the Russo brothers
so you have the original down here
and lovely idea it's pretty good to
bring together a group of remarkable
treated to see if we could become
something more that's tight
so when they needed us we could fight
the battles
[Music]
so epic
Marvel Studios marble next time you will
know what it's like to lose
yeah that's really good dan the timings
all point to right that's a fail all the
stack Wow
[Applause]
Dustin's still alive
you guys in the back
oh my gosh you engage audiences
and get this manna sheet
[Music]
[Music]
fun isn't something one considers
imbalance
[Music]
this great
[Music]
good job
oh hi
[Music]
nice that's really good that's gonna be
so sick
[Music]
oh I was really good gonna be so cool oh
it reminds me of our Wolverine trailer
with dinner
oh yeah which we did not get any
attention for I know that about you too
back then has to be either really good
or really shitty and ghetto like this
one it was really shitty it was really
great I never said it wasn't this one of
my favorite things out that you slapped
me remember what if there is a brother
say about it so they've tweeted this
house they said because the person that
tweeted it was Iman Iman you guys are
geniuses are you available to dress
though I thought it was like a man I
thought so too but then I looked at who
tweeted in that's his name all so funny
yeah and he caption it originally this
parody captioner who did it better at
Marvel Studios hmmmm the other guys did
know the timing was really good though
cuz that's that's really really hard to
do that's the kind of friends you want
dude the ones that just sit around do
dumb [ __ ] with you they weren't fully
committed to this I think that was us in
college hmm that's how it all started
that was original YouTube yeah oh my god
that wasn't yeah [ __ ] what happened to
YouTube man I miss it yeah and just like
you could just do a video like once or
twice every now and then yeah I mean it
was just fun oh those are the days I
mean we can kind of bring it back and
then we can try to do it well I think
we'll try but then who's gonna pay the
bills I know everything up it's all the
algorithms like they push up the [ __ ]
daily vlogs and like all these kind of
you know it's different they don't
really push up the talent livestream is
words that now yeah but you can't do
that on live stream though how do you
live stream a skit or a show or feature
found yeah you have to sit there and I
can't do a live play I can the thing is
I can't do no for our live stream man
that's a talent you talented
that's a thing that you could do to be
able to sit there from why can't do that
funny because that's what we do every
and we have bricks Libre I've done live
streaming I can't like I feel like I've
only done an hour to Mack yeah and I was
tired yeah and I was mentally exhausted
but you're talking to us
[Laughter]
no I'm talking to my friends we're
talking and then other people are
watching us like arguing with her when
she's on I'm not like in a group setting
of like a group of like eight people
like human beings like I could touch and
do something it's different you're
you're because you're explaining it how
you feel I'm telling you why I don't
like because I've done streaming before
on different platforms and it's too hard
this is wait but more fun for me to
actually have a person to interact but
what if like if it's a jet like you
don't justify yourself like what is Joe
talking to you you as it shouldn't like
shooting a wreck I still one person it's
not eight they work with a JK livestream
it's the same thing if we're playing a
video game I think I do it yeah cuz I'll
just be talking to you while I'm playing
the game and I can't do it for four
hours four hours is that's a sport I
know everyone wants us to do JK lay on
down another four hours I'm tired it's
like a specific type of person has to do
it yeah I mean like it's not easy like
to be able to sit there and do that it's
not easy like I like there's been
companies that have offered me like a
lot of money to do it I tried it for
like twice and I couldn't do it I can't
even watch horror movie it's way too
long hmm I just can't do it it's just
not it's not in me
[Music]